This is Berk, son.
It was the home of your grandparents and their grandparents before them.
But out there, beyond the age of the world, lies the home of the Dragons.
And I believe it's your destiny to one day...
find this hidden world.
You do know my leg isn't a chew toy don't you?
Is this what you want?
Go get it!
Uh, how am I supposed to get down?
Hey bud, wait up!
He's not the only one.
Another Night Fury.
It's more like a Bright--
A Light Fury.
Yeah, yours is better, probably.
There is an armada, with enough cages for all of our dragons!
This is a new kind of enemy.
We need to find the hidden world.
I will destroy everything you love.
Toothless! NO!!
Your nothing without your dragon.
If Grimmel succeeds, there won't be any dragons left,
and it's up to us to put an end to it!
So what are you gonna do about it?
Suit up gang!
We have one shot at this!
You brought a baby to a battle?
I couldn't find his sitter!
The Hidden World... It really does exist.
Now that's a King.
Your right, bud. It's time.
Well, look who it is!
Not a word.